more and more treatments and ways to
prevent copin 19. coming out weekly
infusion therapy is now in high demand
after covet forcing many to stay away
from the hospital and medical offices
christian spoke to a local woman about
how this trend is helping her boost her
immune system he joins us live in studio
with her story christian well sherry
goldstrom we met her today and she tells
us that she is doing what she can to
stay healthy and avoid getting sick
during the pandemic she's now using a
home immune remedy check it out
nowadays you know it's most important to
worry about our health and take care of
ourselves sherry goldstrom is hoping to
get a boost in her health after feeling
under the weather over the last few days
i kind of thought i had covered last
week but it was just a bad cold it went
through my whole family any other
symptoms you're feeling today no just a
lot of sinus pressure today she is one
of many seeking reset iv an immune home
treatment packed with vitamins amino
acids and powerful antioxidants that
helps build up her defenses reset iv
nurse james mados explains how it works
it's going directly into your
bloodstream
is bypassing the gastric intestinal
tract so that your cells can actually
get it more effectively and a lot more
faster than
a supplementation all right let's start
the treatment there's just been this big
misconception that you only have access
to it in the urgent care or the
emergency rooms and historically that's
mostly been true and what we're bringing
is we're delivering the highest level of
that technology in the comfort of a
person's home as omicron continues to
sweep across the country telehealth is
exploding according to the cdc residents
like goldstrom are doing what she can to
protect herself because she says
vaccinations can only do so much they
make you feel like an amazing person
when you're done
and with covid and all the crazy things
going on in the world today you know
wellness is the most important factor
well goldstrom says the effects of the
iv usually kick in between 30 minutes to
maybe a few hours after the treatment
but overall she says it's done at home
or at work and most importantly away
from the crowds christian casa is live
local now